plus loin vous christophe dans cette
bonjour les diplomates européens ont
donc en un mois à bruxelles ils sont en
train de plancher et un ca y est pour
définir ses sanctions contre la russie
aux dépens des sanctions qui pourraient
être adoptées cet après midi par les
ministres des affaires étrangères réunis
en ce moment à paris sur un autre
dossier hier encore il envisageait des
sanctions a limité dans un premier temps
mais elles pourraient être plus
importantes que prévu ces sanctions la
présidente de la commission européenne
hors sol à fond derrière a dit que
l'objectif serait de couper la russie du
système financier international la
grande bretagne devrait elle aussi
adopté des sanctions en début d'après
midi avec une stratégie similaire suivi
ensuite des états unis hier soir le
président américain joe biden a publié
un décret avec une première salve de
sanctions qui ne vise cependant que des
personnalités actives dans les régions
séparatistes de l'ukraine donc des
mesures limitées d'autres mesures plus
importantes pourraient suivre dans un
deuxième temps on les voit ici
s'attaquant au système financier russe
aux exportations de haute technologie et
puis surtout aussi au gaz c'est menace
de sanctions il faut le dire elle se
répercutent déjà sur les prix des
hydrocarbures qui eux s'envolent le
pétrole d'abord la russie faut savoir
est le troisième producteur de pétrole
au monde et le brent flirte désormais
avec les 100 dollars le baril je
regardais ils montent à vue d'oeil et
vous voyez il est à 99 dollars très
exactement au plus haut depuis juillet
2014 les bocks d'une autre crise et
craignait et d'autres sanctions visant
la résine avec des risques évidents pour
nous ici en europe d'une envolée des
prix à la pompe qui atteignent déjà des
records le gaz aussi beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur le sur les prix du gaz
les prix du gaz coté à new york s'envole
également aussi ce matin de plus de 3% 3
7% très exactement ce moment même alors
certes il est encore moins aux qu'il y
encore quelques semaines ce gaz mais les
éventuelles sanctions sur le gaz russe
devrait avoir des conséquences sur les
prix pour les particuliers en europe
alors qu'ils sont déjà très haut en
france tout de même le pdg de f d'edf
veut rassurer il ne devrait pas y avoir
d'impact sur notre facture puisque le
gouvernement français a décidé bon sens
vient de plafonner les prix jean bernard
lévy était le l'invité de nos confrères
de france info ce matin les gouttes il y
à une forte augmentation des prix du gaz
à l'entrée en europe et ceci a conduit à
une forte augmentation des prix
d'électricité sur le marché de gros cela
dit au sein des différents pays
européens chaque pays a eu sa propre
réponse pour éviter que les prix de
l'électricité augmentent de trop et la
réponse du gouvernement français c'est
les prix de l'électricité en 2022
augmentent de 4% alors jean bernard lévy
qui estime aussi qu' edf va comment va
normalement continuer à commercer avec
la russie malgré des sanctions
éventuelles mais que cette crise
ukrainienne est de nouveau un révélateur
du fait de la nécessité de ce fait de se
défaire de l'as de la dépendance
européenne au gaz russe surtout qu'en
cas de sanction moscou a déjà menacé les
européens de fermer les robinets de
gamme alors pour le moment ce matin les
ministres le ministre russe de l'énergie
affirme qu'il n'ya pas de qui qui n'est
pas question de réduire les exportations
de gaz mais larmes de la fermeture du
robinet c'est très reste une arme
redoutable qui sanctionnerait
immédiatement les européens qui sont
extrêmement dépendants c'est vrai du gaz
russe près de la moitié des importations
de gaz proviennent de russie avec de
forte hétérogénéité l'autriche importe
quasiment l'ensemble de son gaz de
russie la finlande aussi autour de 80%
alors que l'espagne n'apportent rien ou
quasiment rien la france n est
dépendante qu'à 20% environ et du coup
les européens christophe ils cherchent
des alternatives aujourd'hui des
alternatives qui ne sont pas faciles à
trouver il ya la norvège il y à
l'azerbaïdjan au le japon aussi même les
états unis et puis et puis le qatar le
qatar
qu'ils aient accueilli ce matin un
sommet ordinaire du forum des
exportateurs de gaz dont la russie fait
partie sauf que le qatar est bien il est
déjà sa capacité maximale de production
et n'a donc pas beaucoup de mains de de
marge de manoeuvre donc on voit bien que
la situation l étendue et acéré père
quitte aussi surtout sur les marchés un
dernier mot justement des démarches et
de la forte nervosité surtout sur les
bourses mondiales
oui d'abord évidemment sur la bourse de
moscou avec ce risque de sanction qui
inquiète les investisseurs en russie
après d'avoir déjà perdu 10% hier le mot
excellent indice de référence de la
bourse de moscou
perd également ce matin plus de 5 7%
après avoir ouvert en baisse de 7%
l'annnonce de la banque centrale russe
qui se dit prête à prendre toutes les
mesures pour faire face à l'instabilité
financière et qui affirme que la
situation pour le moment elle est sous
contrôle semble éviter un effondrement
plus marquée en europe pour le moment
les pertes sont assez limitées le cac40
ne perd que j'avais dit à 0 5% le dax à
francfort 0 7% on verra surtout cet
après midi à wall street à new york
quelle sera la réaction de cette bourse
de new york sur wall street qui était
fermée hier pour cause de president's
day merci beaucoup christophe dans cette